hey what's happening thanks for tuning
in to another episode of led to be
taught the [ __ ] and files brought to
you by my great sponsor earthquaker
devices out of Akron Ohio devo man which
matter of fact if you foam on Instagram
right now I just saw that mark from Devo
mother's burg is is doing a like a live
thing at their place today pretty
[ __ ] cool that's awesome yeah so
earthquaker devices sponsor for two
years amazing you play any kind of
instrument or or if you just want to
look cool by one of these stomp boxes
and throw it in your house people go
what is that it's a stomp box dude from
earthquaker devices anyway check them
out earthquaker devices calm how are you
spicy I'm good dude I just uh I put out
a little web series are you doing for
sure oh yeah I saw you showed it to me
secretly yeah a while ago yeah they came
out for shorts about marriage and
they're doing well like I kind of put
them out not a lot of promo behind them
but all my youtube which is Christian
Spicer 713 youtube com Christian Spicer
713 representing h-town yeah but people
seem to be date like it's like people
are either like oh my god these are too
funny or people reply like this is too
[ __ ] accurate oh yeah yeah I always
saw one so did you tweet it I didn't see
that I would have tweeted it I put out I
put it a few times the kind of one just
to see how they do but i can i'll shoot
the link out here in a little bit people
can check them out they're all in the
youtube for up there yeah it's kind of
we didn't and then video game news
blizzard the big company there make
great amazing games they released their
newest game over watch it came out
yesterday officially today but early
release yesterday I games fire Dean it's
looking good now here's something I was
going to ask it like is it did the games
come out on all the car how many
consoles are there now like two
different gaming console units like when
I was growing up it was what was it a
Sega and Atari right yeah well it
changes right now there are there's the
pc like computer and then the xbox one
and the PlayStation 4 and the Nintendo
has the Wii U but it's kind of dead and
that's an old one where it's like you're
playing sports that's the Wii the Wii U
is just a whole
named next console that doesn't quite
work that way but they've retired that
console more or less they have a new one
coming out next year but right now it's
like the PlayStation 4 and the Xbox one
sony and microsoft are the two dogs in
so when the game comes out they make
them for both the thanks most of the
time there'll be a few exclusives you
know like if it's made by sony they're
only be on the Sony platformer Microsoft
or whatever but which one's better the
platforms game platforms I would argue
the PlayStation 4 right now that's the
better ya better console I remember I
was with D'Elia on the road I don't know
a year ago or something maybe even a
little longer two years ago and we just
want weird walking around the mall went
into game place I don't play these games
yeah cuz I know what's gonna happen on
[ __ ] house I am [ __ ] smart yeah
like oh so there's some car racing game
there and it's like you're racing in
Monte Carlo or something and the [ __ ]
thing was so real yeah I was just like
like racing this Ferrari down the
streets and [ __ ] and immediately I was
hooked as i [ __ ] out of here yeah and do
you know were like how great are these
games you know it's easy to complain
about a lot of [ __ ] right now but at the
same time it's like yeah it is an
incredible time to be a gamer and the
quality and the amount of triple-a
awesome [ __ ] games that are coming
all the time and say how much are the
games 60 bucks more or less so you know
that's one of the reasons like America
doesn't go out anymore hahaha because
they just buy a bag a weed on Friday
they get like a good you know quarter
ounce of some chronic and then they get
a sixty-dollar game they take some bong
rips pop that game in next thing you
know it's [ __ ] sunday at two thirty
in the morning they got to go back to
work yeah it will melt some days away oh
my god right just like ah yeah now when
you're playing the games it saves the
spot you're at right yeah most games
have pretty generous checkpointing
system so you don't lose a bunch of
progress it's not like the old days we
had to beat mario and one sitting or
like leaving the console on no mom no
like it or they or the real old days
where he had to just keep pumping
quarters yeah try to get all the way
through something I still love pitfall
I'm a pitfall guy ah but uh yeah you
know I was just I was just thinking like
you know once you get bored of that game
too then what are you just a bit yeah
you can ebay it sell it backs a lot of
the publishers now are trying to make
that harder to do yeah where they'll
have like a one-use download code in it
so if you buy the game new you get for
extra little characters or you know
different maps for multi players like
that so when you resell it you don't get
as much for it but there's a pretty
decent second-hand market still and
aside from just collectors cuz we hold
on to the it's like CDs it's like oh I'm
gonna put it on my shelf or than you do
any like why the [ __ ] toys yeah that's
so dumb
so done because you know the consoles
changed too right yeah and then you got
these games that that you need to keep
some old console around too and it's a
constant battle at my house right half
getting red [ __ ] yeah and then some of
the old consoles can't even hook up to
the new TV like I'm out like an adapter
something I wanted your own maybe I have
a place for it and you're like fine with
me yeah you need a TV to keep around to
play some games I play once in a year
yeah you know that's why I stick with
records it's the same thing it's the
turntable the amp and a record you put
it on you go yes yeah I want to get I
think I've talked about this offline
some I want to get a nice little well
nice Beach anima just like a little
suitcase record player so that I don't
need it's not great quality but I have
it in my office and it's like built-in
I'll change a tube once every 20 years
for something I gotta get that one I was
saying they used him in junior high and
elementary school it's got the built-in
speaker I got one for a friend and it
sounds so [ __ ] good so it's like it's
the ones that I hadn't [ __ ]
elementary co you come in they click off
the top it's got one speaker here put
the record on three speeds got 78 on
this yeah I know one has four cat a kid
like maybe Fahmy wait you remember what
when I was a kid I thought you said when
you were [ __ ] a kid no on 78 when I
was a kid though I had big bad wolf on
78 and I put on on the slow speed and he
just Satan but yeah man that's a great
one and they and they look cool too and
what what made me want one was I went to
some hipster party yeah and it was in
the backyard and then they had one
they're plugged in and records were
playing they said a stack of kind of
ghetto records so people could just [ __ ]
around put him on I was like that is
genius you know just some records in the
backyard and yeah that's Sabbath and
[ __ ] coming out of this old elementary
school and and it sounded
great yeah I mean it sounds what you pay
for it yeah I can talk receiver and a
ram but it's like salad but it's just
cool right like you're in a backyard
playing records yeah you know that [ __ ]
is badass yeah uh tomorrow we're gonna
see the who yeah yeah it's just gotten
free tickets out of nowhere yeah yeah
they're not the best seats but it does
not matter are they free and are they at
the staple center let's go you know they
had a workout but um I seen the who in
82 and I tweeted yesterday I said I'm
going to see the who on Wednesday night
which is funny because I saw him an 82
on their farewell tour so I guess they
were just kidding and this thing has got
to be one of my biggest tweets and years
right now he keeps building blown up but
I saw the who in 82 they had the big hit
eminence front out at the time okay and
Keith Moon had died and they got kenny
jones from the faces okay and they were
going out there going to tour this is
supposed to be their last time stones
did 81 tattoo you tour oh that's
probably going to be it for them 81 and
then who farewell 82 Oakland Coliseum
the clash opens the clash has the combat
rock record out oh yeah and they're
humongous you know it's should I stay or
should I go and rock the casbah and all
that it was a [ __ ] great great day
and I remember the tickets back then
were so hard to get farewell tour always
a [ __ ] and it was an incredible day and
here i am seeing him 2016 I wasn't
really thinking I was going to go see
him and my buddy at Berman text me
tweeted at me two days ago he said holy
[ __ ] go see The Who I went and edit it
is one of my oldest friends but he saw
Hendrix you know he's seen every one he
did coke with Duane Allman not his first
line Oh allegedly ah but um when he says
go see something yeah uh-oh I better go
because he's like me seeing everyone
says its kind of oh yeah
magana but I saw the who won Fallon
about two months ago okay I was like
this guys [ __ ] sound great I mean is
rocking yeah you know I'm Pete Townsend
what I'm legit huh it's incredible then
they've kept they haven't had a you
haven't heard of them having like a bad
tour or a batch like a lot of bands you
here but like the one it's like all you
in an 87 yeah that was the bad year yeah
brightest it you don't hear any of those
horror stories about the who you don't
hear about them being total [ __ ]
[ __ ] like they're rock and roll no
they've trashed some [ __ ] I'm sure yeah
but there's none of these horror stories
about them or like being dicks or trying
to screw each other over all your
management getting in the way except for
that Townsend [ __ ] daughter that dark
[ __ ] of Townsend for a while home and
you know it is really crazy on uh who I
still trip out on it their bass player
dies at the [ __ ] hard rock yeah
cocaine and hookers just straight rock
it like 60 the next day or two days
later they play the Hollywood Bowl
you're the [ __ ] fill in guy I'll i do
man that is gangster yeah what are you
gonna do you got a date you got to keep
the day wow wow you know but uh i'm down
to see it i'm seeing the Cure tonight i
know it's there while i'm working at
their setlist 32 song where are they
playing hollywood bowl that's gonna be
crazy the set list is unbelievable man
to get in and out of Hollywood before
that show starts oh yeah oh you're so
right it's funny when I grew up I hated
the cure but I liked him secretly sure
because there was such this line drawn
in the sand it was a lot like Prince you
didn't want to tell people you out you
know but with the cure it really was
these goth girls yeah that would hang
out at like coffee shops and stuff with
the pale face and the black hair and the
black lipstick and they would smoke
close I never forgot it and then they
would just you back when you could smoke
and sad places no just smoke these
cloves and think they were so [ __ ]
cool yeah okay and they were really
always like beautiful that I could
love but it'd be like you're a gross
rocker get out of here that old thing
you know it was such like it's a lot
like um like breakfast club haha you
know I'm there I'm the bender guy with a
flannel and Levi and a cigarettes and
you know fingerless gloves yeah and then
you got the ally sheedy character then
she would be the killer and then you got
the girl that I really liked was the
redhead one Molly wing was like the
preppy cheerleader girl yeah a little
misunderstood yeah I feel like the Cure
fans like that when when they were newer
it's built even today still they are
still annoying cure fans in high schools
across the country all right they annoy
me the same way some weed donor heads
stoner heads anoint it's like I love the
music I'm fine with the culture I'm not
fine with like the deep dive fun it's
like I get it yeah you smoke weed weeds
great of course but it's just like don't
grow [ __ ] the dreads uh dude 422
kuan-yin I'm a weed calm i only do calm
and we'd come it's just like that that
blows my mind someone is such a [ __ ]
weed head everything is weird about them
yeah anything they talk about like that
you see it for 20 dude like everything's
said around their life their got dreads
you know they they play the tons of
video game eh we got a call we got a
call all right let's check it out hey
what's going on you're on the air who's
calling you a cigar from her ha what no
I uh I thought I us this is the acting
da for North Carolina oh yeah Kanye West
you got the right show all right what do
you want to talk about Kanye about oh
yeah Ellen the whole like crazy figure
he did oh yeah Baker just a Rob based on
him doing DNT and now that indigo
movement is like suppose we started oh
yeah
at totally Kanye is a master at
self-promotion anytime Kanye does
something everybody thinks it's so crazy
you're talking up you talk about Kanye
for four months like that dude is so
calculated in what he does and he is
never never crazy I believe that when
Kanye is at home instead of like zodiac
killer you know in the movie they have a
bulletin board and the threads
connecting everything Kanye has a huge
[ __ ] wall that's just like my crazy
wall and it's like time since last crazy
thing time to next crazy what am I going
to do when am I going to do what I'm
going to call i'm going to interrupt
Taylor Swift here four years earlier so
that I can reference her in a lyric in
my album that comes out in 10 years
dudes a [ __ ] after mind [ __ ]
mastermind I think that marriage is
fixed too probably that's just a sham of
publicity you know what I mean yeah yeah
because we kind of prophesied about
marrying a porn star la two hours ago
yeah yeah well he I don't know if she's
a porn star I think those two words
together hilarious horn and star but you
know how to make one of your rich I'll
tell you what though I love music I know
all kinds of stuff about music I'm
engulfed in music I don't I don't know
anything about Kanye's music I hear it
and I just go yeah really yeah i just
cannot i can't i can't take it man
there's just nothing people like juniors
here a scene Kanye you know like I see
them live and I just it just doesn't
grab me man you know you have to be in
three references in somehow like crazy
like being a guy that's how I Duncan
truffles comedy it's all third I you
know I really I really want I really
wanted it you know like I think with
Kanye to me is there's not enough music
for me compared to all the other [ __ ]
that I get from him of I Kanye did this
and that oh you
there's too much of the other side for
me to enjoy what's coming you know what
I mean I love outlaws and I love rebels
and and guys that speak their mind but
when it's all that I'm just kind of like
you know like I love Oasis and there was
it was great they had killer music and
they would battle and fight and [ __ ]
that's good combo you know but uh you
know wait wait till he gets divorced
then I'll start listening to probably a
great record like Bob Dylan [ __ ]
blood on the tracks hmm thanks for
calling in that favor later at first I
thought I was a fake all I think was
just a bad Skype connection it seemed
like it was a little uh maybe he's in
like the hills of North Carolina and
didn't have them oh dude okay call them
with an actual topic yeah how'd I mean
yeah instead of like hey how are you
guys it is interesting they could
today's music or ever today everything
and you and I both are aware of this and
into this machine to as well with like
Twitter Facebook snapchat whatever but
like how relevant Kanye stays for the
amount of music he puts out he puts out
a decent amount of music right but he's
not Elton John in the 70s no no not you
records a year like all the people in
the 70s yeah he's not cranking out
record after he put out a single then
he'll tease a record that's only
available on title then four years later
another record and but he's relevant all
the [ __ ] time yeah and so he's always
seems only about five rappers right you
got like Drake you got Kanye you got
what Chris Brown like these I'm just
saying these are guys that that you only
hear about I'd say it's like the weekend
Kendrick Lamar yeah
as I oh god my mind's blinking Drake
Drake yet night Kanye it's like five six
dudes the main main street once in
awhile jay-z comes around yeah we got
another call hey there hey hey hello
who's calling where you calling from
thanks man from San Diego what's going
on and then are you guys good today
what's at the church you today now it's
me and Spicer we're both here okay cool
right what's up man how's the house of
Diego treating you beautiful weather
today says equality had you know Peter
if that works for them I saw you guys
with five before they fall in all right
on man you got any questions some kind
of been on my mind lately about ebony
was probably for a couple years now and
you know eventually I'm going to have to
think that you're moving out of San
Diego in a few years now kuranda tunic I
feel like you know with comedy thing so
popular right now it's become more
interesting you need to move somewhere
other than New York and LA and I said I
was wondering know if you have how much
experience that Ravel I think York will
be a fun place you know there's a whole
new comedy scene I think what I think
comedy is spreading around the world the
United States oh yes you're doing call
me I'll and things like that are you are
you a convict sorry I didn't hear are
you a comic or just a fan of common
there's a comic okay it's been doing
comedy two years okay cool cool yeah
sorry I missed that it's funny because
that you say that because I was just
talking to a guy 2 days ago about I
can't remember who it was but they
Bronston Jones sale hey there's this guy
coming to town he [ __ ] destroys he's
big in Europe and he's from Toronto so a
lot of Toronto guys are Canadian guys I
guess they go instead of New York or LA
they go to
london and [ __ ] like that and fire up
Carly so man I mean I don't really know
anything about the international scene I
see its getting bigger and bigger bird
just toured it twice Marin also and and
louie ck you nessa it's just weird yeah
anecdotally you know there's the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival which is huge
and you'll have a breakout artist go
through there Australia will not Europe
but the Australia comedy scene continues
to boom and then like the English like
you know based hubbed out of London you
know I have a couple of friends Russell
Hicks who I haven't hung out with and a
couple of years now but we came up
together any movie I go he moved there
and is just super [ __ ] funny yeah
yeah so it's available wherever you go
but I also wanted to overlook something
like Minneapolis Chicago Denver Austin
yeah there are some great scenes outside
of LA Harlan also yeah for sure thanks
for calling dude yeah yeah thanks later
yeah that's interesting like like you
know how scary it is to move to like say
LA or New York like oh god I imagine
moving somewhere out of the country
where you don't know anything about the
comedy scene yeah and where you're gonna
live and all that man that's just extra
[ __ ] wait on you it seems like you
know like uh well I'm in another country
now some extent I wonder and I having
not done it I wonder if that makes it
easier in the sense that you're you you
either go all in or you move the [ __ ]
home in a year yeah right but I almost
feel like like I started comedy in San
Diego and i love the san diego comedy
scene but when I came up here to LA I
didn't feel like oh man new big thing
I've been driving up for yours already
there's not like this super tight knit
group of San Diego comics that are now
in LA even though there are a bunch of
us yeah but it's not like welcome let me
let me show you the ropes oh I feel like
if you move to London again just just
imagining I could I could envision it
being a tight-knit community of expats
that are like dude welcome let me show
you the ropes let me show you around
this is what you got to do and you
literally have nothing
to do because you don't know [ __ ] all
about who well yeah I think I don't know
I don't know what the immigration laws
are or anything but can you just show up
and start working yeah like cuz you're
gonna need a day job yeah you're not
just showing up with a pile of money and
then go I'm gonna just start doing
comedy are there are there laws like hey
you got to get a work visa all that [ __ ]
you know which is probably one hundred
percent true yeah so that's got to be
completely really weird you know so you
would have to do so much research that I
think at the end of the day unless you
had a buddy that was like I did it
here's exactly what you do yeah because
I also the scenes are so different
leather styles like London comics are so
different then American comics you know
if you if you you know go over there all
sitting you're just going to be like
maybe you learn a whole different style
you come you trying to come back over
here and I go well that's that one I
don't know I think if you really want to
try something different go to somewhere
cool like Denver is really cool the
comedy works yeah they have a system
where they let their they actually pass
people like the comedy store and they
get to a host and feature for the
headliners when they come in and they
rotate them every night so when I'm
headlining it's two different guys each
night you know we got a call what's
happening who's calling where you come
from all right it's piggy from
Connecticut how are you buddy good how
you doing man good man it's me and
Spicer today you got any questions
yesterday well I got comment man ha you
know you guys would love to patrol
around that genes term and I think Kanye
West doesn't fit that but today is a
true genius for Bob Dylan god damn right
man [ __ ] yeah that's a real genius i
I've seen well assume over 40 times and
I'll never never disappoints me did you
just read that thing today in the new
york times he sold his archives
yeah it was on week million yeah but
here's the thing they valued it at 60
million but he really he sold over 20
million uh and then donated the rest
like I guess something on Kansas City or
something I think I couldn't believe it
because one of his handwritten lyrics to
song last year sold for two million
bucks yeah i think it was blowing in the
wind one of those um this thing they
just brought it out today talking about
it today the amount of [ __ ] like I right
now at my house I have it's so funny I
have everything of my life yeah and in
my mind I'm like well man if I'm ever
famous they're gonna have a whole
[ __ ] shitload of stuff here it's such
a lunacy thought that's not what I'm
thinking but I just I can't throw
anything away there was something in my
house I went to Coppola when he first
did the apocalypse now redux which is
the full movie version i went to the
screening he handed out these these cool
pamphlets this is just one in a million
items i have thinking like why the [ __ ]
do I have this but I cannot toss this
it's so [ __ ] cool you know and it's
been a hard time right now with my CDs
and like DVDs what the [ __ ] do i doodle
well if you listen to us about two
months ago you can get rid of those I
had a we did a full episode on get rid
of those immediately because that's
different I'm talking about I don't know
it's I think it's something to me that
doesn't want to release them you know I
mean right well yeah then I think it's
just acknowledging that you're holding
on to it not for the CD not to listen to
the CD but just for the nostalgic
because like I have cases of old video
games that once a year i'll go down to
the basement and open it up and look at
it and to me that justifies keeping
those four boxes i'll be like oh yes
madden 04 like no one wants that [ __ ]
game it's so [ __ ] i love pulling out
an old double album and find in like 30
year old seeds in there
you know that's what I don't know what
it is man in the human that makes us
pack rats even if we're not those ones
they shoot TV shows about i'm tellin you
dude I've whittled it down and there's
still boxes of [ __ ] in my house right
now I've lived in there five months the
new place and I just walked right by it
and I would walk by it for 10 [ __ ]
years I don't know why I need to have
this I really don't know why but I can't
toss it a lot of it is just genius rock
and roll memorabilia so what my little
brother started doing and I don't know
how far he's gone with this but he
started doing is with things like that
like knickknacks or whatever it helps
that he has like his wife and other
people in his life are amazing
photographers yeah but he would take
pictures like of that pamphlet from
Apocalypse Now he would take an awesome
picture of it yeah and then save it and
he has like you know it's like backed up
five different ways so it's all saved on
his computer so he just goes through and
looks at him that way and I think he
printed a couple of like really nice
Prince of these photos of these things
so now he has a piece of art right of
the ticket of Metallica from 88 or
whatever I get that it's a really cool
way that he's decided to like make peace
with I can't keep all this [ __ ] up but I
still want to look at it I'm even a
bigger weird of thinking like I don't
even have people at my house so it's not
like come on over oh they don't think
let me tell you story about that on 78 I
dropped acid saw bucket that's not even
that that's what's [ __ ] crazy about
it to me I'm like an absolute lunatic my
point on this is as i was reading about
the dylan [ __ ] there was so much stuff
he meticulously saved everything and
they said it was all in primo archival
you know conditions you know that's like
well movies everything ram movies I
couldn't believe it lyrics letters like
there was a postcard from from [ __ ]
Barbra Streisand in 1978 he had that
there was a telegram from dennis hopper
and and peter fonda saying thanks man
for letting us use this song on
easyrider all this [ __ ] man and I was
like goddamn that's cool I think it's
really cool and I think I wonder now and
don't get me wrong i'm a big fan of the
digital age yeah but it's like that
lyrics the handwritten lyrics oh let's
just say it was blowing in the wind two
million dollars like what is that what
is that today it's like oh here's the
hard drive any of the lyrics a Dracula
said yesterday I was like we're never
going to have any at separate that's why
I like too hard right jokes and in in
little booklets yes yeah I don't move
Don from that and it kind of sucks that
I but it's earth like oh here's this
print out of this email Dean sent me
it's just weird we don't have that yeah
we're doing I gonna have it's like you
know we don't have any Charles Bukowski
diary sitting around you know it's it's
a crazy thing but it's it's it's amazing
because they had all these lyrics and
I'm sure you read it too how many times
he changed like ballad a thin man you
know and you're going like wow I keep
here for such a reaction versions of the
song dignity holy it's got cut from the
album yeah we're just [ __ ] crazy and
they were all on different hotel
stationery which they were showing his
work ethic every night after his show he
was writing and rewriting these tunes
until he recorded him and it's
scratching out lyrics and changing
lyrics and [ __ ] I was like this is
incredible you know that's a Sanford
kpop yeah just like Kanye he does the
same thing thanks for calling in again
see you buddy there later before we
moved on from like comedy scenes one
thing I do need to plug and give a shout
out to I was in Salt Lake City yeah this
past week dude that for like a city
that's easy to write off as just like Oh
Mormons or like Utah which I don't come
with mormons in the first place but like
they won't get it well that's just a
happy thing you know they're Mormons you
sleep nine wives and new booze on
Sundays I ever hear like really that's
the whole thing of a [ __ ] Utah what
about [ __ ] Park you know like the
film
festivals and all the great skin and all
the breweries right there is such an
indie brucine going on in Utah but the
Salt Lake comedy scene just incredible
there are so many funny comics just from
the three shows I did there and I put
together a grip of time you know I think
I headline three shows and did you like
three hours awesome but what's the name
of the big club there deliah said it was
one of the best he'd ever done wise guys
yeah like the amazing he says it's
[ __ ] incredible Lisa it's like comedy
works you know that cool actually so
that's the I haven't performed there I
did a bunch of all shows and like indie
theaters I was booked there like maybe
two years ago they had a different venue
and then that venue closed right and
then now they have one downtown Salt
Lake and then one in ogden utah it's
like 40 minutes outside Salt Lake so it
was like literally at the time I was
booked at wiseguys they shut it down
like two weeks before I was going there
haven't been back but the scene is great
if you're in Salt Lake you know go go to
your shows go to local shows check out
wise guys check out some of the indie
scene this guy Christopher Stephenson
for a while i was doing this comedy
carnival festival out of salt lake he's
great Jason Harvey's a guy he'd putting
up a bunch of his own shows cool that
it's just like it's so cool to go to new
cities and just see sit there and watch
ten comics blow you away Wow I mean just
blow you away they're so [ __ ] funny
well that's great man and then how was
the turn out good it was good one was
light one was really light but it was
incredible like there were some of the
best lappers and just on board with
anything so I got to do a bunch of new
[ __ ] and then the other two one was like
just packed and the other one you would
walk in and go yeah this is full yeah
totally but it was really really cool
and where'd you stated it wasn't
effective as festival no this is just
put together run of shows my wife's
family has a family business in Wyoming
and they meet in Salt Lake's it's easier
to get to so the wife and the kids and
our extended family were all there so we
were all holed up in a hotel and then I
snuck away and have found my sanity on
the stage oh ok I didn't know your wife
wait mm-hmm and the kids yep
I was all day with the kids and then at
dinner time would break out and go to go
to Agrippa shows that's badass it was
fun so yeah we were in the middle of
talking about the cure oh yeah and the
Cure fans yeah and we'd heads what would
I what I think is amazing is the amount
of songs that robert smith wrote man i
mean like how many like they're doing 32
songs on the set 32 and and you're
looking at it you're going hit hit hit
hit the cure is a lot like the cars or
who else like the cars has like 20
[ __ ] hits you go see me I can't
believe how many songs they have and so
I'm looking at the Cure setlist I'm like
I cannot believe this you know and you
can go on it it's a great website
setlist i think setlist calm and you can
just pick a concert let's say one you
went to yeah like 20 years ago that's
opposite like wow there it is and then
you can hit play on each one oh yeah it
has the set list and in a youtube video
will pop up next to it and if you didn't
know the song or whatever but does it
have a picture of the girl that grabbed
the setlist off the stage the end of the
show Stacey's too I was wondering how
they [ __ ] did all these old sellers
but it's just researching and people
that punched in you can add leg that's
on there man but what a great site so i
was looking last night hollywood bowl
there there three nights the cure ok
this is the last night oh they were
there last night yeah and explain it was
a [ __ ] for me to get out of the store
and it was just like what the [ __ ] is
going on anytime it's what the [ __ ] is
going on it's the Hollywood Bowl The
Hardball is the only thing you
absolutely love if you're there yeah but
you hate it for anything else like [ __ ]
that place I think you even hate getting
in and out of there when you're going to
a thought that's the worst like it could
be literally your favorite band giving
you a [ __ ] yeah getting there you'd
be like [ __ ] this place it's crazy i go
on the motorcycle which is genius
go right up up to the ballpark a park
and walk right in two feet away and any
other way I'm like this sucks [ __ ] this
place I'm gonna buy a bike just for the
two times I go to the bully yeah God
they got great shows this year the
Sabbath's playing their last show there
yeah elo is playing up boy george coming
up oh really helping that good culture
club like culture club or a culture club
that's great I don't like DJ Boy George
I like oh no yeah yeah but that that's
[ __ ] crazy I saw Boy George at the
Greek I called you club with eat with it
great Wow yeah so okay so we're gonna go
see The Who tomorrow yeah and that's
gonna be insane 51 years of the hill
that's crazy yeah have you seen who I
have not i've done a bunch of what i
would consider their gin rock but i've
never seen the who i've seen Tommy yeah
which is talkative the who oh yeah yo
you mean you weren't saw it live
somewhere yeah Broadway play when they
were in when i was in new york and it's
incredible like a lot of ever seen Tommy
oh it's so good Wow I think you well I
mean it's a musical but hey whatever but
I feel like the who is one of the rock
bands that pulled it off we're like you
too or bono or someone wrote the lyrics
for the spider-man Broadway show and
it's just like oh maybe that spider-man
fiasco [ __ ] awful you to like a guy
died lots of I think like two people
yeah they said it was the most unsafe
show ever and yeah and then they they
were working on the show for like 23
years and you two would actually be like
the highest amount of making money band
of all time but they've had like these
things that happen in like the spider
mad thing and you got to give it up to
them they take chances like yeah let's
let's do the spider-man thing and there
you know way we just lost 60 million
dollars you know yeah that uh that
soundtrack isn't great unfortunately
they do tours where they make no money
huh because the show is so big oh sure
so high they go well yeah they're making
like 20 million at night but the show
cost 21
put on you know but they don't care i
love it yeah they just go full-on
[ __ ] Super Show yeah all those bands
that do super shows inside I'm like I'd
love to see this Banette like you know
just straight up at the Troubadour yeah
you know like a thousand dollar ticket
or 5,000 or whatever and you get to see
him at the Troubadour no [ __ ] not
just for guys playing music I bet they'd
still kill it I mean that idea that's
the best thing about LA or if you go to
South by Southwest or any of these like
festivals where they have indie stages
and you can sneak into things it was
probably five years ago now i don't even
know I could look it up but South by
Southwest and I don't think he's the
greatest musician ever but Justin Bieber
came in interested in acapella set and
it was just like this kid can sing yeah
just seeing weird [ __ ] he's a brand
piece of [ __ ] probably but like you see
him just singing you know not dancing
not in a shiny suit or whatever and
everybody knows you two can kill it but
yeah I don't need to see hologram bono
reaching out and like holding hologram
the edge like fly around the [ __ ]
arena yeah just watch them shred it's
like princes a Super Bowl performance
okay I'm just gonna [ __ ] shred yeah
me and a guitar that is still one of the
epochs it's crazy Yeah right man it's
funny did you watch the billboard music
was that what was a couple nights ago I
don't even see these award shows anymore
because it just kind of like oh yeah you
know it's like three or four popular
performers and then just a bunch of like
boring stuff well they're so I don't
even I can't I don't know I love music
but it's like I don't know do they mean
anything like the American Music Awards
Grammys the mtv music I think the
Grammys would be the ones that I would
care about the only one what it like
live nation was like what the [ __ ] it's
just what is all that stuff I'm produced
TV show really what is it you know like
these people it almost just seems like
they're all just promotion machines
whoever's are big that year let's get
them on they're going to promote
whatever they're doing and then they get
some award that doesn't mean anything
yeah I mean a Grammy an account
me award are the two to me but the
Grammys you know they went way [ __ ]
down the tubes compared like Academy
Award i think is still the [ __ ] king
yeah you win one of those it's like it
means something Academy Award winning
actor I think it's the only award to
worry being nominated is an award like
if you get nominated right tatamy award
that that means something that has
weight like I was nominated for a Grammy
yeah okay yeah that didn't mean [ __ ] oh
so was i find so funny yeah that's it's
funny because they'll use it you know
there'll be like Academy award-nominated
actor yeah you know Billy Jack yeah whoa
man he must be a good actor yeah yeah
man I mean it holds that weight yeah it
does and I don't yet know ones like
Grammy Award winner Beyonce like oh I'm
gonna go to that show off side yeah I
don't know it I think also again not to
throw too much love Bieber's way but he
had an Instagram post whatever was after
this award show kind of just talking
he's like look I love my fans I'm
honored to be able to do what I do for a
living but it's like this stuff sucks
like I don't care it's not what I want
to be doing yeah and I can't imagine
that promotional machine that you're
stuck in where it's like you go to the
MTV Music Awards to do this thing then
you got to be on the red carpet for well
you're everybody else a chance I'm oh
yeah yeah and it's just I just want to
do my [ __ ] and not make my fans happy
not and they laid on it i'm not going to
happen because there's 90 dudes that
need you to do this so they can all
drive 911 and i'm in which is crazy that
sucks which by the way is that as subaru
as a WRX wagon really happening it's
copying in Japan they're doing it well
it got its not a WRX I figured the name
of the body is but it's an STI wagon and
it's currently announced only for Japan
but it's not a WRX know it's like a gone
or it has a currently the body has a
different name oh but then they're doing
an STI variant of it but who I it's got
to come out here oh yeah you get mean it
has to write I was talking to this guy
today which I had no idea
you know the Ford Raptor truck yeah I
thing's a beast 50 not a great ride yeah
two of my friends have one these things
I guess they haven't made it since 2014
they skipped 15 and 16 now they got a 17
coming out that makes sense yeah these
things have a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar premium on
so the 65 grand but you can't get it for
65 grand you know you got to pay 25
grand on a truck and then you know like
all these people so my buddy's been
driving his for like three years now and
he's gonna sell it for almost the same
money he bought it for almost exactly
the same for a [ __ ] truck there a
beast of a truck oh they're so
incredible yeah but man what a what a
market also the new ones are coming out
i guess in 16 okay 17 right it is only
way yeah and everybody's like lining up
to get one yeah I'm not of i love the
vehicles and I love you know you and I
will text about dope cars I'm not a fan
of paying markup when like I was going
to buy a shelby gt500 when they first
started coming out again and whenever
that was 2005 but it's just the markup
on them like I love the car but i'm not
gonna pay twenty thousand dollars over
MSRP for [ __ ] mustang I don't know it
must think it is not when there are so
many other awesome cars out there yeah
so it's like at the end of the day you
know I ended up buying a Porsche but
yeah but it's like you look at other
cars and I guess I'm just not that big
of a fan like go get me wrong I'll pay
you no more money to get the limited
edition paint job or something like that
taller but i'm not going above and
beyond now the cost of the [ __ ] thing
it was the reason i didn't buy the go
far member yeah i'm not saying i go to
buy the VW Golf R and I'm in love of the
car great car I test ride it I'm like
this cars [ __ ] killer and then we get
back in the guys like well I said what's
the pricing goes it's this angle way
that's five grand more and he's like
yeah there's a mark upon these I go yeah
but VW isn't summon one [ __ ] car
right now because he's got busted for
that diesel sit down
there's not a [ __ ] soul here yeah and
he's like yeah sorry it's a markup on
these they're really rare and I go yeah
but there's no one on your life yeah and
VW is in the tanker right now it's in
the toilet they're getting sued yeah
there's all kinds of models that fall
apart everything like one of the worst
rated cars in in the biz and and they
were trying to get me to get a pay a
markup I just said see you later it's a
short sightedness where I think some
diehard fans like you need that thing so
you will pay for that thing to me we're
in such a wonderful time of automotive
industry where there are so many choices
yeah los every type of model line I wait
up seaStreak you a block away got the
car that was even better beautiful the
WRX it was it was like it had less turbo
lag the see the body inside was way
bigger and felt comfortable and it
looked [ __ ] cool yeah it was great
and yes annoying too because it will
kill some great cars whenever I 99
whenever they brought back the Ford pop
rock the t-bird it was kind of that
retro-looking t-bird those things were
carrying five to fifteen thousand dollar
markups on it and then they quit selling
because no one could get them so Ford
quit updating them and so here is this
beautiful car that a lot of baby boomers
were interested in that possibly fizzled
out because dealers were just so [ __ ]
greedy trying to make money off the
first 20 that they killed a whole
product line and now for it only has
like one performance I guess now they
brought out the focus in the Fiesta have
a performance variant too but it's it
it's frustrating as like a call
enthusiasm an it's his crazy is like you
know like I was just reading the new
rolex daytona yeah came out everybody
wants of course New York Times yeah does
a story on it and they said the day that
it came out the Rolex dealer in
Manhattan there was a line of like 20
people at like 5am or whatever you know
just to get on the list so the watch is
uh it's a new york call yes we have your
watch yeah watch is a 13-2 or 12 7 or
something they said but they said it's
going to be more
dup 5,000 bucks that's a whole other
Rolex that's another one and that's how
I look at some of these motorcycles like
when they first Harley was doing it for
a long time they were marking up these
SI VOS and now they're other bikes are
so [ __ ] good that the CBO's just sit
around you know and it's like because
you don't want to buy something like buy
one of those cars a raptor and and
you're paying 25 grand that's another
car you're driving an invisible car
inside that car yeah there are very few
things that I would I think be
comfortable paying a markup on it and
I'm not trying to belittle people that
do it's their money spend it as you but
to me there are enough comparable things
in almost every market that I'm there's
very very few I can't think of one thing
where it'd be like yeah I'm gonna pay
more than what I should pay for it well
I always think about like if I was rich
and I was buying a home I could be
[ __ ] in these battle big battles you
know a place is because I'll walk into a
place to be like oh this is the [ __ ]
the one hahaha you know and then you got
to think there's like maybe three other
guys going this is the one and you get
into a battle and then you buy it and
later an earthquake comes and your
property value goes down and now you're
upside down cuz you bidded the [ __ ] out
of his house you know sometimes there
are three pretend people that the
selling agent lies about well it's very
competitive yeah went on our last place
they tried it and they were like yeah we
offers come in at this and I was just
like well that's more than we can do now
well I mean there's Sun tomorrow okay
great well I mean they're gonna start
why do you keep calling me
congratulations you said yeah no no no
you don't i'm just like [ __ ] you like a
few days later so the owner decided they
liked you better shut the [ __ ] up uh
yeah decided yeah well these two
strangers we don't want to make an extra
50 on them you seem like 90 90 Bobo else
like come on man I wish for a lot of
things I wish you could just in this one
I practice law to one of the
frustrations I wish you could just sit
in drop all the pre-tax
drop all the [ __ ] just be like Dean
do you want this phone how much were you
willing to pay for it 350 great uh I
except instead of like yeah I mean
hypothetically if I was gonna get rid of
it for like 500 and you're like no it's
just like tell me the [ __ ] thing
that's how i buy cars if I used to buy
cars I would go in first of all I do mad
research yeah find out with it now they
got that website what the cars are
selling for around in your neighborhood
and [ __ ] I find out exactly what the the
invoice is on it and everything and then
I would make it fair like okay the guy
used to make a little money and I would
go and I go this is what I'm paying yeah
and i'm leaving here right now not
sitting here going like ok and move to
this box and then move to that [ __ ]
boxes and this guy is going to come over
go sorry that guy didn't know what he's
talking about this is it i go i'll be up
the street eating dinner yeah if you can
do this price i'll be here after dinner
if not don't worry about it yeah and and
either they say ok or no but sometimes
they'll [ __ ] try to say yeah no
problem then you'll come in and they'll
sudden they do a [ __ ] shake and fake
yeah and you're like whoa what the hell
that's why I think it's so people just
hate buying cars yeah you know yeah cuz
I mean that's very similar to my
approach and I didn't invent it but I'll
do the research put in the ground work
or the legwork to know a base and know
what I should expect to pay know what
I'm happy paying so I'm not trying to
get the best deal necessarily like [ __ ]
I need a car i'm willing to pay this
much or whatever and then i'll find five
dealerships that i'm willing to drive to
and then i will call them and i will
call one and say hey I'm looking for a
you know 2016 prius model to I don't
care about what color any of the other
options I don't care about just a model
too what's the best price you can give
me i'm going to call for other
dealerships the person who gives me the
best price i'm going to buy the car
today yeah I am NOT going to call you
back yeah and they'll hemin hall for a
little bit and if it's too long a bit
okay well bye it'll give you a price
then I call the next dealership and I
don't share the prices no I
call and and that's all I do and if any
of them come in with the range in which
I'm willing to pay I will go and buy the
car if they don't I i I've [ __ ] up my
research somewhere and all i'll tell you
down and do it again I'll tell you big
bummer yeah is when my buddy called me
and said hey will you call an see what
kind of price you can get these [ __ ]
grab your number oh yeah i forgot
they're like star 6 7 11 but unit locket
and man they'll call you yeah every day
yeah hey what's going on man that's a
Tony over your pontiac firebird hahaha
you know you said i got no no no and
even if you say i bought a car thank you
yeah oh man that's too bad man what kind
of price did you get yeah what we do to
get you in over here yeah I bought a car
yeah trying to get rid of him there they
go well I want you to keep us in mind
for your next car and it's like dude you
know see you later young oh what a
nightmare these [ __ ] guys will just
cold call you in the morning yeah did I
tell you about I might have been driving
here i got called like a you know
solicitation some spam call and i was
driving sitting in LA traffic so i just
had fun with the guy yeah tell you the
story oh it was like chatting with them
and he's like asking all these questions
and Ike start off with x mi serious
answers yeah and then because the guy I
figured he set up front just oh it was
it was some like scam yeah I was like I
need you to go into your computer and
hit and enter the following code and it
will clear your computer of all viruses
oh I'm like hack you know how many
embarrassing and he's like are you front
of your computer and I'm like yep he's
like okay enter this thing and I go okay
Niko's you did it and I go yeah oh wow
that's incredible it did it cleared all
my viruses yeah another guy was like
what it did they're waiting for the next
thing to father you know like oh yeah
that's great that's awesome thank you so
much uh can I can I give your number to
my mom she would love this and he's like
like I kind of lure him back in there
like the at the end this guy who didn't
sound American which is fine whatever he
then goes you sound gay Wow and I just
go I go excuse me he was close you sound
gay and I was like okay yeah and he was
like how do you feel about that like I
feel fine about it how do you feel about
it and he's and I kept like
oh yeah anyway I had so much fun Oh
laughing my ass off cuz I didn't care
but now because of that yeah I get so
much oh yes are you [ __ ] [ __ ] you can go
online and block out your number
somewhere forget what a well I think
this is like some Nigerian scam like I
don't think this is like they respect
that do not call registry every time
they call i still [ __ ] with them I'll
hang up like this one got calling he was
like I forget what he led with but I
could just tell and I and he's like are
you over 50 years old and I go depends
did you like Batman V Superman if you
say no I'll kill you oh hang on dumbest
[ __ ] but I get like for a day all right
let's get out of here I'm gonna go see
the Cure will see the hooter mon and
then we'll talk about it next week
thanks guys for calling in and keep
leaving reviews you can donate at
patreon.com / Dean Del Rey and candles
Lutz have a good week Oh